vous vous sentez blanche vous vous
sentez noir
parfois je me le demande en fait je ne
sais pas
je me sens albinos surtout
l'albinisme c'est un phénomène génétique
et un rapport avec la pigmentation
qu'est-ce que c'est qu'un pigmentation
c'est une substance chimique qui
a des répercussions sur la coloration de
la peau et au niveau vie au niveau
vibratif le poil et la couleur des yeux
oui et oui vous avez aussi des problèmes
de vision oui on a un champ de vision
assez restreint plus ou moins important
j'ai un vingtième de vue mon score
représente un demi dixième alors j'ai un
champ de vision assez réduit mais qui ne
m'empêche pas de véhiculer dans l'espace
quotidien comment voyez-vous votre image
moi je me sens bien dans ma peau j'ai
admis mon état physique et bon j'essaye
d'en tirer à l'heure actuelle toutes les
avantages bon je me lance un petit peu
dans le cinéma et à travers ma
particularité ma différence caractère
originalité
essaie de
jouer quoi je me réparticiper dans la
grande fête du cinéma dans le monde du
travail du cinéma
de tout le monde donc j'étais petite
très blanche avec des cheveux couleur or
très longues et j'étais très différent
des autres
et ma grand-mère qui m'a élevée
m'a toujours inculqué l'idée que j'étais
la plus belle que j'étais aussi bonne
que les autres même meilleur je suis né
au Cameroun à Douala dans un pays situé
sur l'équateur en Afrique il fait
environ dans les 35 ans en degrés à
l'ombre et c'est une terre qui ne
convient pas du tout aux albinos vous
vous sentez blanche vous vous sentez
noir
parfois je me le demande en fait je ne
sais pas
je me sens albinos surtout
mais vous vous sentez mieux dans un
milieu de blanc ou un milieu de noir
je me sens mieux dans un milieu de blanc
parce que l'expérience me l'a appris
quand je suis dans un milieu de noir je
suis
moi bien accepté que dans ce milieu de
blanc et par ailleurs dans tout mon
entourage je suis entourée que de blanc
comment les gens dans la rue vous voient
vous avez des réflexions est-ce que vous
avez des souvenirs particuliers ah oui
dans la dans la rue il n'arrive que les
gens me fassent des réflexions très
méchantes genre une fois acheté dans le
métro
je marchais vers le quai et deux
personnes ma foi très mal habillées
me disent oh elle s'est trompée dans
l'autre Jamel
est-ce que vous pensez que vous avez une
vision particulière de la vie étant
donné le fait que je suis albinos étant
donné aussi le fait que j'ai une santé
très faible que je pense donc que
j'aurai une vie très précaire je prends
je prends la vie telle qu'elle arrive
j'essaie de profiter de tous les bons
moments qui arrivent je n'essaye pas du
tout de regarder les mauvais moments
bien qu'il y en ait parfois dans la vie
vous pensez à la mort oui la mort pour
moi c'est une
délivrance une libération je pense que
quand je serai morte je n'aurais plus du
tout de tâches enfin je me sentirais
vraiment libre
qu'est-ce que vous faites dans la vie je
suis étudiante kinésithérapie je suis en
dernière année et j'ai 100% d'invalidité
parce que j'ai un 20e à chaque œil donc
je touche allocation du handicapé pour
ce je suis très indépendante je prends
le métro toute seule j'ai pas de
problème on pourrait la lecture j'ai mes
lunettes avec la loupe et puis pour la
télévision ou pour aller au stade ou
n'importe quoi j'ai au monoculaire
c'est tout simple ça tient dans la main
et puis c'est comme une jumelle en fait
voilà
c'est pas tellement le handicap visuel
qui est gênant c'est le problème
physique et les gens se gênent pas trop
pour le faire remarquer par exemple
qu'est-ce qui qu'est-ce qu'ils disent
les gens qu'est-ce qu'ils disent ou
comme elle est blanche
tiens mais elle a peut-être les yeux
rouges faudrait aller voir il se déplace
et quand ils sont en groupe pendant le
métro c'est ça me fait mal parce qu'ils
se sont encore plus fortes moi je suis
toute seule alors ils en profite ils
disent ça un petit peu leur science mais
si ça se trouve elle y voit lui ou enfin
bon tout ce qu'il y a de légende
il vous est arrivé des histoires
particulières justement à ce niveau là
une sortie de boîte un garçon qui
j'attendait une amie il vient se planter
devant moi et puis il me fait
qu'est-ce que tu es moche toi
un peu amusé parce que c'était vraiment
le gagne et puis
tu es vraiment moche je me répète au cas
où j'avais pas entendu j'ai dit oui
alors ceux que j'y fasse
la peine pour toi je remercie bien sûr
c'est gentil t'inquiéter pour moi mais
en fait j'ai pris ça sur le temps un
petit peu ironie j'ai rigolé mais le
coup était très très dur et j'ai
vraiment du mal à me remettre parce que
parce que c'est
idiot c'est méchant c'est la méchanceté
vous vous sentez différente
moi oui pas à force les choses au sein
de la famille non parce que même avec
les amis je me sens pas différent parce
que font pas la différence c'est par
rapport au monde extérieur c'est eux qui
se chargent de me le remettre en face
tiens tu es pas comme les autres toi
t'es blanche toi tu es petite tu es pas
bronzé tu as les yeux qui bougent
et moi sinon ça va j'arriverai à
m'accepter s'il y avait pas s'il n'est
pas ce problème et tout de même à
l'école déjà quand vous étiez petit oui
quand j'étais petite oui c'était c'était
marrant ça phénomène j'ai repensé après
c'est que je me suis retrouvé toujours à
l'école à côté d'une camarade qui était
antillaise il y a pas eu la fréquent une
fille de couleur et sans que ce soit
c'était assis entre nous c'était quelque
chose comme ça c'est peut-être le fait
qu'on soit minorité l'une comme l'autre
donc dans des extrêmes
qu'est-ce que vous aimeriez dire aux
gens par rapport au fait par rapport au
physique que vous avez
c'est à dire que nous ne sommes pas des
lapins c'est à dire qu'on n'a pas les
yeux rouges on est des a tout à fait
normaux c'est juste c'est juste comme
s'il y avait un film ou quelque chose si
c'est une couverture qu'on a qui est
différente l'intérieur est pareil nous
sommes aussi intelligents que les autres
nous raisonnons de la même manière nous
sommes pas des pestiférés on n'est pas
contagieux ça s'attrape pas les
ministres il n'y a pas de problème on
peut il y a aucune raison de pas avoir
des contacts avec nous et nous regarder
comme des bêtes curieuses nous sommes
comme les autres la couleur est
différente
[Musique]